one of the things i've been talking
about for a few weeks now
is what i see is the underselling of the
coronavirus vaccines
as something that could well be making
people
less interested in getting vaccinated
when you see
endless headlines about even if you're
vaccinated you can't do anything
differently you can't hang out with
people you can't do indoors
you have to wear a mask you can't travel
you can't visit anybody all of this
different stuff
and we've been expecting new guidelines
from the cdc
in conjunction with the dramatically
accelerating vaccination
numbers that we talked about yesterday
and we got it
the big news to skip to sort of the meat
of the announcement
is that the cdc now says vaccinated
people
can safely gather indoors without masks
with
other vaccinated people without social
distancing
you can hug vaccinated people can also
be with unvaccinated people if the
unvaccinated people are of low risk and
there's a few other things let's look at
cdc director uh walensky telling us this
yesterday
cdc recommends that fully vaccinated
people can visit with other
fully vaccinated people in small
gatherings indoors
without wearing masks or physical
distancing remember here we are talking
about
private settings where everyone is
vaccinated
so what does this mean if you and a
friend or you
and a family member are both vaccinated
you can have dinner together
wearing masks without distancing you can
visit your grandparents if you have been
vaccinated
and they have been too now
i want to talk to you about another more
complicated scenario
it involves vaccinated people visiting
with unvaccinated people
when fully vaccinated people visit with
unvaccinated people
we have to consider the underlying risks
of the unvaccinated people
and any unvaccinated members of their
household
we take this approach because all of our
guidance is rooted in making sure we are
keeping
people safe so
cdc recommends that fully vaccinated
people can
visit with unvaccinated people from one
other household indoors without wearing
masks or physical distancing
as long as the unvaccinated people and
any unvaccinated members of their
household
are not at high risk for severe covet 19
disease
so additionally vaccinated people can
gather indoors
unmasked with unvaccinated people
from the same household assuming that
the unvaccinated people
are low risk so the point here is
the vaccines are extremely effective
all essentially 100 effective at
preventing serious covet and death
uh and they appear to reduce
transmission more on that
in a moment and on this basis
it is time for certain elements
to start going in the direction of
re-normalization now
vaccinated people should not go hang out
with a high-risk
85-year-old unvaccinated person
fortunately
increasingly a majority of those over 60
have now been vaccinated at least with
one shot in the united states majority
not all
to put it a different way vaccinated
grandparents
can visit unvaccinated healthy kids and
grandkids
but vaccinated kids should not be
visiting unvaccinated
grandparents um i i will be paying very
close attention to this household thing
being vaccinated myself my girlfriend
being vaccinated i have friends who are
couples and work from home who aren't
yet vaccinated
that seems safe and that's in accordance
with what the cdc says
two couples from different households
especially
if one doesn't work from home i'm not
going to get into that kind of
situation for the foreseeable future so
this is a big step forward
the science seems increasingly clear on
how effective these vaccines are
at preventing death serious illness
increasingly clear that they also reduce
transmissibility
although that's still being studied the
cdc said yesterday
a quote growing body of evidence
suggests people who are vaccinated
are not only less likely to have
asymptomatic infections but also
potentially less likely to transmit the
virus
still they aren't ruling out the
possibility
that a vaccinated person could
inadvertently transmit the virus
we're going to learn more about that
over the coming weeks and months
also from the cdc yesterday vaccinated
people don't need to quarantine or get
tested if they have a known exposure to
the virus
assuming they don't develop symptoms so
this would be
you find out someone you work with if
you're working in an office
someone you work with has tested
positive you are vaccinated
you do not need to go through an
isolation and quarantine protocol if you
are vaccinated
unless you develop a symptom um
vaccinated people
should be avoiding large and medium
gatherings still everybody should
and of course none of these guidelines
change
anything for vaccinated people out in
public if a grocery store says
masks then everyone wears masks
regardless of vaccination stat status
that should be obvious
that makes absolute perfect sense so
hopefully and we're going to have a very
interesting interview later today with
jonathan berman about
the vaccine hesitancy which is
fortunately waning in the united states
on the covet vaccine
hopefully this increases the number of
people who get vaccinated since
the more that that do get vaccinated
number one the more people that can get
into this new protocol
outlined by the cdc but also the faster
we can go to the next step of relaxation
of guidelines now some states are just
relaxing all guidelines now
texas mississippi some other scheduling
further relaxation is going to
wide open everything no masks anywhere
i believe that there will be people who
will want the
vaccine because now it's in black and
white from the cdc you get vaccinated
and your parents do
you can hang out and you can hug and
these are things that
many people in parts of the country
haven't done
for um really almost a year we're about
a week from
the one year mark from the trump
announcement that travel from certain
countries is being banned and sort of
the beginning of
quarantines for those who have been
doing them
that's what's going on in terms of what
vaccinated people can do
let's now go to our weekly covet update
as to the numbers which continue to
improve fortunately
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled
with the idea of going into a doctor's
office right now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's
no risk no commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video